pneumonia is inflammation in your lungs
caused by an infection
you have two lungs one on each side of
your chest
each lung has separate sections called
lobes
normally as you breathe air moves freely
through your trachea or windpipe
then through large tubes called bronchi
through smaller tubes called bronchioles
and finally into tiny sacks called
alveoli
your airways and alveoli are flexible
and springy
when you breathe in each air sac
inflates like a small balloon
and when you exhale the sacs deflate
small blood vessels called capillaries
surround your alveoli
oxygen from the air you breathe passes
into your capillaries
then carbon dioxide from your body
passes out of your capillaries into your
alveoli so that your lungs can get rid
of it when you exhale
if you have pneumonia your airways or
lungs have an infection caused by germs
such as
bacteria
viruses
fungi
or
parasites
your airways catch most germs in the
mucous that lines your trachea bronchi
and bronchioles
hair like cilia lining the tubes
constantly push the mucus and germs out
of your airways where you may expel them
by coughing
sometimes germs make it past your mucus
and cilia and enter your alveoli
normally cells of your immune system
attack these germs which keep them from
making you sick
however if your immune system is
weakened due to age illness or fatigue
pneumonia-causing germs can overwhelm
your immune cells and begin to multiply
your bronchioles and alveoli become
inflamed as your immune system attacks
the multiplying germs
the inflammation causes your alveoli to
fill with fluid making it difficult for
your body to get the oxygen it needs
if you have lower pneumonia one lobe of
your lungs is affected
if you have bronchopneumonia many areas
of both lungs are affected
pneumonia may cause the following
symptoms difficulty breathing
chest pain
coughing fever and chills
confusion
headache
muscle pain
and fatigue
pneumonia can lead to serious
complications
respiratory failure occurs when your
breathing becomes so difficult that you
need a machine called a ventilator to
help you breathe
bacteremia occurs when the bacteria
causing your pneumonia move into your
bloodstream where they may travel to
infect other organs
in some cases of pneumonia a large
collection of fluid and pus called an
abscess may form inside one of your
lungs
if an abscess forms around the outside
of your lung it's called an empyema
possible treatments for pneumonia
include
antibiotics if the cause is bacteria or
a parasite
antiviral drugs if the cause is a flu
virus
anti-fungal medication if the cause is a
fungus
rest and drinking plenty of fluids
and over-the-counter or otc remedies to
manage your fever aches and pains
if you have severe pneumonia you may be
admitted to the hospital and given
intravenous antibiotics and oxygen
you